a secret deal reportedly allowed some of
the most notorious Isis fighters to
escape from a besieged Syrian city with
their weapons our partners at the BBC
say 250 fighters were permitted to leave
Raqqa they got out with 3,500 family
members to Isis controlled territory now
the report says their convoy included
nearly 50 rented trucks 13 buses and
more than 100 Isis vehicles 10 trucks
were loaded with weapons the BBC says
the US and British led coalition knew
about the deal brokered by Syrian
diplomatic forces democratic forces
rather and they actually monitored the
Exodus
here's an excerpt of Quinten
Somerville's report the world was told
only a few dozen local fighters were
being let go nor foreigners and no
weapons but the trucks were crammed full
of Fighters some wearing suicide belts
all were heavily armed after days of
searching we picked up the trail
at a truck stop on the outskirts of
tadka here we discovered the drivers all
civilians who drove is to freedom
they've been hired by the Kurdish led
Syrian democratic forces it was the
longest journey of their lives their
trucks were rigged with is bombs in case
the deal collapsed they've been told
they were picking up only a few hundred
civilians that it would be a quick job
they ended up driving day and night for
three days this couldn't look like the
Islamic states escape to victory
so the SDF insisted there will be no
Flags and no banners instead is vital
sat boldly on top of the trucks the axle
on one lorry broke it was so overloaded
with is weaponry Pentagon spokesman says
the United States was not part of this
deal but the spokesman also points out
the u.s. was not prepared to bomb buses
full of women and children